[Musique]
mercredi 14 décembre c'est en musique
qui a démarré la dernière séance
plénière de l'année 2022 pour le conseil
départemental de la réunion après un
concert de l'Orchestre des collégiens de
la montagne et une prestation de Natacha
tortillard salué par les élus la matinée
s'est poursuivi dans l'hémicycle à
l'ordre du jour figurer l'examen du
budget primitif 2023 de la collectivité
qui s'élève à 1 milliard 265 millions
d'euros une augmentation de près de 47
millions d'euros au bénéfice de notre
territoire et de ses habitants première
chose il y a pas d'augmentation donc les
fiscalité au niveau de la du département
donc nous nous appuyons sur ce que nous
avons comme ressources et recevoir ce
qu'ils sont certes liés à la conjoncture
économique puisque les principales
reçoivent la fiscalité sur un milliard
300 millions d'euros c'est environ 550
millions d'euros qui nous proviennent de
la fiscalité cette fiscalité elle dépend
beaucoup de la con voiture taxe sur les
carburants taxe sur le tabac les droits
de mutation et la TVA depuis que la taxe
d'habitation était supprimée en France
donc il est un budget ambitieux et
volontariste car les recettes dépendent
la conjecture mais ne dépense dépend de
la réalité des besoins sociaux et ça le
département est formel il nous faut être
à la hauteur des enjeux des enjeux
notamment de la population qui est
vieillit la PA par exemple des enjeux
autour de l'eau c'est un sujet important
dans le contexte lequel nous sommes
actuellement un certain nombre
d'impératifs qui donc qui conditionne
aujourd'hui un budget qui doit être à la
hauteur de désespérance le vote du
budget primitif 2023 du département
intervient dans un contexte économique
et social difficile pour autant la
collectivité réitère son engagement en
faveur des Réunionnais et du territoire
conçoit le budget d'une collectivité
comme le département de La Réunion est
un exercice anxiogène parce que nous
devons trouver le juste équilibre entre
la réponse et les recettes entre les
politiques publiques qui nous permettent
d'apporter des solutions par nos
concitoyens tout en protégeant nos
finances publiques et c'est un exercice
qui faut faire de façon
clairvoyante déterminer mais aussi avec
prudence parce que nous n'avons plus de
Tommy fiscale nous n'augmentons pas la
fiscalité nous devons travailler avec
les dotations qui nous sont octroyées et
mon combat est celui des élus du
département c'est d'aller rechercher des
recettes supplémentaires dans les fonds
de dotations au niveau de l'État au
niveau de l'Union européenne pour poser
des financements pour nos politiques
publiques maintenant le vote est une
chose mais l'exécution du budget sera
une autre chose c'est pour cela que nous
avons gagné la première étape qui est
l'adoption du budget maintenant il nous
faut gagner
l'étape la plus importante qui est de
réaliser les actions les opérations que
nous avons prévu et c'est là aussi que
nous sommes volontés et aussi très
engagés ce budget s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la mise en œuvre du plan
de mandature validé il y a un an et
traduit une réelle montée en puissance
dans plusieurs domaines l'habitat la
proximité renforcée l'action sociale
l'insertion l'aménagement du territoire
la transition écologique et solidaire ou
encore le développement agricole pour en
savoir plus sur la répartition des
dépenses liées aux missions du
département rendez-vous sur notre site
département 9 7 4 fr
[Musique]